uh what inspired you was it someone in
your family was it like to start rapping
so early you say you started rapping at
five right yeah I mean that's pretty
crazy I mean like what was the
inspiration with behind just wanting to
get involved in music in the first place
we we oh my I'm gonna say my
my perspective of it is is uh
when we I'm gonna say my perspective
what got me in the music was Ryan and we
would go down the road we're going to
interstate going to you know see the
city with me and woman [__]
and
you know she was a Beyonce your mom she
would be gonna say she was Beyonce what
do you mean by that
she she was Beyonce God damn it like
every day we listen to Beyonce again
okay okay so your mom was bumping the
[__] out of Beyonce and she you couldn't
tell her she wouldn't be anything okay
okay and then they'll be honest and yeah
I get so tired of hearing that [__]
but too much Beyonce invitation like but
growing up right growing up man [__]
you're saying this is growing up
he's before seven now
oh it is
so we traveling and [__] and
and Beyonce I was on the radio I know
I'm always
pushing this [__] off you know what I'm
saying all right we're going on the road
I'm screaming stop in the car man I
ain't trying to hear this [__] like and
we end up finding me some music
so she wouldn't let me know at the time
you know [__] we were listening she was
listening to Yo Gotti
female female rapper so she should help
me a rapper yo got in but Beyonce but uh
and she prayed Yo Gotti when Beyonce
wasn't playing
so they said I go Yo Gotti yeah that's
how I can end up getting my my time in
because I ain't wanna hear that [__] so
I could I could at least today [__] and
she she said um the first thing she said
she said I was in that [__]
trying to I was in there being reached I
probably like she said about four or
five I was in that baby saying pure
cocaine and writing that [__]
down to where I can remember that
[__] and and she
I made my first song when I was like 87.
yeah so have you met Yo Gotti yet
hey man Yo Gotti I'm gonna be real I
ain't really into mean people though
I I mean why not Yo Gotti that'd be kind
of cool you could explain that to him in
person like hey bro you know when I was
five years old it was because my mama
made me listen to that that was the only
choice I had you feel right you should
have made if she would have cut on
anything yet but Beyonce you would have
been into it
whatever it was as long as it wasn't
Beyonce yeah so it's like I ain't I
ain't gonna say like [__] that was my I
ain't doing nothing like that that was
just the only access of music I had to
at that point right and it went from
dead to growing up that was all you had
in the hood like when nobody you can't
get no music through Mississippi right
they ain't gonna let you you feel me I
don't even know how he did it to be real
he had to go through people in this [__]
because I don't see him just pushing
music through Mississippi you can't just
push me through Mississippi you gotta
know people there like it ain't no just
getting it through there so he had to
Bootleg and [__] everywhere in the hood
that's all he seen and see him one cm2
cm3 seeing and you listen to everybody
in the hood just bumping and [__] you
feel me so [__] just go through it right
there you know just catching on as I
made it down to Mississippi when I'm six
years old like she able to comprehend
what's going on and [__] this you know
what I'm saying like it just was like
what it was you and your mom are on the
road a lot you said yeah like from all
the day all the time we ain't never sit
down until seven oh [__] ubering or
something what's going on ain't doing no
Uber we don't need play like this I'm
just I don't know
you're not gonna let y'all do that
um